readings this episode of The Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by on it on it for all your supplement
needs go two hundred that calm right now
I'm press in church BAM and get ten
percent off this podcast is also brought
to you by utopia California listen you
[ __ ] know I'm which star one
gummy bears but there's been a butter
macaroons or put a [ __ ] hem in
your skirt and they're vegan correct and
Grisha and kosher like a [ __ ]
rabbi could eat it are you [ __ ] nuts
or what one of your life no-parole in
studio my main man Action Bronson flying
Jew give me the half and half wild
[ __ ] traveler of the stars hit it
it's the Church of what's happened down
[ __ ] Monday August 14th
tomorrow
29 days 29 years I got sent to prison
29 years congratulations man are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] them or what are you
[ __ ] nuts qualia live [ __ ]
haha oh [ __ ] it's a church hit it up
what's happening now
Monday Tuesday [ __ ] action in
the mohel Lisa at in the [ __ ]
house let's do this do this I love
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
thank you for a great weekend in San
Francisco last week I think action once
the dank San Francisco - sure thank you
very [ __ ] much how many nights did
you do up there it was uh it was two
nights was phenomenal phenomenal
phenomenal we did a little intimate
setting 500 people on Saturday the night
before outside lands that was [ __ ]
crazy some [ __ ] beautiful women in
the front row they definitely wanted to
have sex
I was acting sadiddy' because I love my
woman you know at the end of the day my
dick is on a shelf but it's a nice shelf
you don't I mean it's a Columbian shelf
you get temptations on the road but men
were men there's beautiful women
everywhere but you know home is where
the heart is it really that's really
neat this there's nothing like having a
good woman there's nothing like having a
[ __ ] good woman that supports you and
that's what I got you know a great
[ __ ] man when I was a kid once he was
older than me we're talking about
something at this time he was very
successful in a gas station he was doing
a thousand things and I said think this
chicks got the hots for you are you
gonna give her a stab he looked at me
goes why would I
he goes I got a woman at home that was
there when I had $2 now that I'm rocking
and rolling I'm gonna cheat on and I was
like you know what you got a [ __ ]
points [ __ ] bullsh I get tempted we
all get [ __ ]
you know I'm getting old I'm 54 when I
see like two 19 year olds you drive
around
you see like a 19 year old couple like
an 18 year old couple holding hands with
schoolbooks you know they're going on
the [ __ ] and they got till 5:30 remember
those days you know yeah when you head
out 5:35 suck titties
come on this stomach beg them to take it
in the ass bag him to suck your dick had
a cry yeah I got a box of tissues course
you had grandmother
there's always an argument yeah oh my
[ __ ] god
young young arguments over dick sucking
I remember those men couldn't but that's
never gonna happen again
not so never gonna happen again no I had
a couple arguments I have some arguments
here in the over getting my dick sucked
you still do sometimes you know it's a
real life [ __ ] you got it [ __ ] have
an argument sometime over it it's like
you know if you don't get the [ __ ]
hint what do you want me to do you want
me to [ __ ] sit on your head like what
do you want me to do here I won't have
you bill with your woman like for years
now for you yeah for 1718 [ __ ] years
right I can't wait there's no arguing
over [ __ ] no it's for nice little
it's fun arguments it's like practice
it's practicing for being a lawyer now
you had it you have a ten-year-old I do
in a 12 year old from a different I do
from do different well have one did the
same one so you always when you and were
you with that baby's mama for a while
well now we weren't together for a long
time we were young 20 years old you know
was young [ __ ] at a young [ __ ] dick
at the time and I was just [ __ ] Wilin
out [ __ ] crazy
yeah man it's like you have to realize
you know you have another child like I
have a child at 26 have no contact with
it for the last 10 years we just don't
talk cuz me and the mom had a [ __ ] up
divorce now I think I got another
curveball thrown at you I got a little
baby at the house so it's all ironic how
you learn in different relationships
it's crazy it's crazy like now I want
this I'll make you I want this
relationship I should this is what this
is hold on man like I [ __ ] think
about getting home to
I want to have another baby for sure I
want to give my woman a child and I'm
[ __ ] fertile I look at her she'll
[ __ ] have 20 in a [ __ ] I'm telling
you I've been [ __ ] I've been getting
women pregnant since 13 now how how many
expanded you how many you messin with
Spanish woman since as long as I can
remember and you love them they're the
ones that drive you [ __ ] nuts you
speak Spanish [ __ ] Brazilian anything
with a tan skin dries you [ __ ] go I
go nuts guy ant Guyanese freaked me out
I love it I used to go to jiu-jitsu with
this girl I don't know what she was
Nicaragua [ __ ] the skin color her
feet
we're nice and like this baby creamy
brown I just wanted to smoke up [ __ ]
feet please [ __ ] olives I got skinny
[ __ ] years and I'm saying this may
give you 16 years if you just grab a
woman's foot stuck in the hair the
[ __ ] like a savage all right this
guy's definitely got a problem that skin
color was [ __ ] beautiful I love
different skin cocking love them love
them I'm CUBAN the land of 92 different
skin colors so you know need a little
[ __ ] you know difference I don't want
to see the same [ __ ] I got the
[ __ ] our baby and Jew is on
this show [ __ ] believe slinging dick
and giving out [ __ ] now you have a new
project coming artist yeah what blue
chips blue chips is just you know I when
I when I first started doing that [ __ ] I
was really thinking about fixing
basketball games and in just the
correlation of me being this new
up-and-comer [ __ ] Nick Nolte's over
here buying my mother attractor bags of
money yeah I mean so I come and play
that's what the whole [ __ ] thought
the thought process behind it was trying
to make it seem like I'm I knew I'm a
[ __ ] blue chipper so I'm shaving
points I'm doing this it was really just
a [ __ ] in my own mind some crazy
should I love that movie
Shaq penny [ __ ] Nick Nolte going nuts
[ __ ] who else is in that the [ __ ]
woman Sarandon
susan sarandon i don't know it just it
it correlated something in my mind and I
just it's one of those projects where I
just [ __ ] wrap my ass awful I just do
whatever the [ __ ] I want I don't even
give a [ __ ] I honestly don't care there
were six people been telling me you got
to get action on the [ __ ] show I
listened to a couple you [ __ ] music
your videos Easy Rider oh yeah the other
one that you got thrown off the [ __ ]
tour well they didn't let you to college
what else ever [ __ ] you know I never
even [ __ ] perform that [ __ ] song
no not one [ __ ] time I wouldn't be
able to tell anybody the goddamn words
people are crazy you're beautiful man
that's why you got a tremendous [ __ ]
rapping style thank you man it's it's
real it doesn't sound like you know
you're pushing you're just talking
that's it that one when you have the old
dudes dancing oh yeah oh my god I was
[ __ ] dying one night in the hotel
room I'm like one of the more haha
Ronson and that's the first thing I saw
what's this video about I have no idea
we just showed up no idea
you got like a weird mind man it'll all
started with cooking that's are you
trying to tell me I mean I don't know if
that's where it started but was the
first time you [ __ ] fell in love with
food like you like gotta get on that
[ __ ] kitchen cook this [ __ ] right
I've been a fat piece of [ __ ] garbage
my whole life I don't know I just love
food from the [ __ ] very first time I
tasted a hamburger on white bread or a
[ __ ] Albanian dish that my
grandmother made what's not baby in like
[ __ ] budak you have a had black no
it's like almost a stuffed pizza but the
dough is a little bit more delicate it's
like a like a [ __ ] baklava Dale
you're that buck yes that was stuffed
with meat but not sweet you feel me yes
something like that
very peasant but very it takes a lot of
skill to make is that the same thing I
like a beret car in Israel it's similar
they have similar names it's a stuffed
pastry ax now you are Banyan and Jewish
everybody cooking
house so what we did when they had you
food neither baby of food but the julu
it wasn't really like I don't know what
the [ __ ] like the Jew is like my [ __ ]
grandparents came to Ellis Island we're
from New York you know my grandfather's
from [ __ ] st. marks in Saratoga right
there in Brownsville [ __ ]
original Brownsville people you know I
mean my mother was born in Brownsville
so then New York Jewish eats [ __ ]
pork she smokes weed [ __ ] incredible
person I mean and she married a very
very strict Muslim man how Bing know
brought his entire family over and it
was just my mom and my Albanian family
so I grew up that way we didn't know but
I didn't know about like Jew for would
unless I went to my to my grandfather
and [ __ ] but it was [ __ ] fifty people
smoking cigarettes in the house
screaming speaking of language I had no
idea what the [ __ ] was going on you know
what I mean this is a crazy [ __ ] time
did you celebrate anything Jewish of
course every [ __ ] holiday that you
can get out of school not what would
this highway be a [ __ ] Muslim say the
other side of my phone you gotta open
the door and let jessimae in what's
what's the dude's name that comes on
Passover [ __ ] eyes I don't even know
it I don't even know [ __ ] like I just
know that this Elijah Elijah this
questions and [ __ ] I don't know what
kind of questions you have to ask some
dumb [ __ ] there's like did like there's
George women who are really good cooks
but like Jewish food kind of sucks don't
you [ __ ] dare talk about Jewish no
cuz okay the pot roast is delicious
latkes are delicious is that all you
know no no there's more but I don't
think whitefish sable yeah salmon I like
salmon but I don't like matzo ball soup
are you out of your mind you like
kreplach
I don't like kreplach soup I don't think
so you like wontons
of course the [ __ ] Jewish one time
what they did apply it's a Jewish one
time that's all that's all it is it's
funny enough to with me okay it's a skin
stuffed so the one time they just put in
the soup the kreplach
they [ __ ] Friday [ __ ] first then put
it in the soup is it one of the ones I
have what's that what's that hot dog
topping that they try to put in one of
those I thought sauerkraut don't like a
tarot card in it are you a [ __ ] Jew
what are you I don't know I'm not really
I'm around you I mean listen there's
just a lot of [ __ ] amazing food APIs
try you know what we don't like pastrami
smoked meats that are cured corned beef
brisket you don't like those pickles
you can't because they pick ah you can't
say pickles what do you get out of
Jewish [ __ ] deli yeah you get pickles
right away no that's who they bring you
that sue listen there's so much what
about [ __ ] husqvarna Kish I'm ears
making up words nice is that something
that's a real [ __ ] noodle kugel with
all that serve I am in the Koshka vana
kitchen but open comparatively when you
say other cultures blowed you Jewish
food out of the water I would say I mean
it's different
the Jews contributed a lot to culinary
history okay ha ha ha it's delicious but
it's bread if I got a deal with so wait
a sec this guy goes on Yelp for food
reviews before you he's the [ __ ] guy
that rides it to listen to me right Jess
alright it's delicious operators you
understand how unique and how hard it is
to make bread good yes yes it's the why
and the Jews have perfected it in so
many different ways but then what
tonight why to keep us with matzo why do
they make us eat months a tree because
they had a [ __ ] get the hell of a tit
and Adam make something quick it was it
was just a snack it's terrible I like
[ __ ] matzah with butter um I like a
lot of things man that's crazy I was not
loathing Jew so you are I guess so you
technically are doers because it's on
your own and I hate and I hate myself
because I believe in the stars what
stars so many of them that are in a star
in the sky the ones that connect three
is that like a various now I don't know
what that is
I think I'm from Queens they call it
synagogue if the Jews don't have the red
string on their wrist I don't know that
one man Madonna Jews
I don't know that [ __ ] dude I don't
wish I know how to [ __ ] cook
I'll take him you might show you some
shine I always easy easy [ __ ] out listen
you're a fat [ __ ] you have ideas like I
know how to dope [ __ ] up I'm gonna take
a steak I'm intolerant to a minyan you
know but there's a there's a certain
thing like I had a friend that went and
was it was trains and all [ __ ] day
and he made desserts and I'm Monday
nights he would make the desserts and I
would sit there with him sample them and
write jokes all night this is my first
time doing comedy but I would watch him
do his thing man I was mystified I just
didn't have the time that put four years
in the [ __ ] killing every Institute
I'd rather work under somebody and learn
how to [ __ ] cook but you know teach
it that's really how you that's what you
[ __ ] learn everything that's how you
learn everything in the kitchen with the
[ __ ] Mexicans are touching each
other's asses and [ __ ] crying
laughing and talking [ __ ] and [ __ ]
cursing at each other that's where you
learn how to cook it's not in the school
like that not I give you the basis but
they don't [ __ ] teach you how to
interact with Mexican dudes and people
in the kitchen and [ __ ] learn how to
[ __ ] cook hard you know what I mean
you've cooked hard very hard like by
volume extremely I've high-volume
[ __ ] heat
I've also [ __ ] cooked on viagra with
my [ __ ] balls we're gonna explode so
I've cooked hard in so many ways that's
crazy whenever i steam a chef in [ __ ]
action you know like orders coming up
he's got two dudes next to him but he's
the Captain Kirk of the enterprise it's
really important I've seen that my eyes
like I drool like that's the [ __ ] that I
get impressed winds phenom and then what
how he tells me how the reason why you
put this sauce was on this dis texture
like okay
let's break some thoughtful thoughtful
let's talk about someone we're talking
about before
please yeah our boy he is Dominican
Puerto Rican I'm CUBAN we had some
flavour to the room so beans got to come
up okay I go to a Cuban join that and
I'm telling this I was I was raised in a
Cuban the house black beans are [ __ ]
frijoles frijoles right I didn't think
about this till about ten years ago you
know you get you get [ __ ] black beans
and you put them on white rice and you
spin it around and you get Li you get
your favorite garlic chicken delicious
and you eat in this phenomenal but then
they got a thing called our immortal
what do I add for the black beans and
rice it's like some type of fat to make
it really [ __ ] some [ __ ] bay leaf
you know you use the [ __ ] black bean
cooking liquid to cook the rice that's
the difference so they take the [ __ ]
white rice and then they mix it with the
[ __ ] black bean liquid and that's
what makes the rice black and it has
that [ __ ] flavor you know what I mean
what's the name of that uh steak
sandwich place in New York Joey the
Cuban on the West New York side yeah no
I can't think about it the cameraman
name I'm too [ __ ] stoned we smoked 82
joints even 16 [ __ ] stars as [ __ ]
stars we think we had a bunch of coupl
couple stems I'm gonna [ __ ] drive home
backwards for [ __ ] yeah you have no idea
these stars are tremendous
that lets players and guess what think I
don't know they got one side effect
hunger like a [ __ ] good thing I
got a [ __ ] big stomach hunger like a
[ __ ]
I got a that's why I finally either
place a weak man hungry is [ __ ] there's
a tremendous podcast people coughing
people took those mushrooms are bogus
Lee mmm highly bogus how you both must
engage these mushrooms no they're nice
everywhere they have him over here this
somebody gave to me at the comedy show
was it a chocolate or was it a full
[ __ ] mush it was a full mushroom cap
the whole [ __ ] thing gave you a
[ __ ] shiitake yeah Portobello they
weren't yeah they wore the bellows they
weren't grown in real cow [ __ ] that was
growing like puppy [ __ ] that's a do
girly stuff like that how many shows do
you have on Vice land man you know I
think right now Matt for Jesus right now
I'm trying to do as many [ __ ] shows
as possible I have a lot of ideas man I
can't let these ideas just go to waste
you an idea babe I just have my non stop
now it's like your favorite one right
now my favorite one is is you know
obviously [ __ ] that's delicious is my
favorite thing in the world because I
get to travel eat ridiculous foods chill
with my friends and that's the show
that's what we do for a living
now you go all around the world with
every [ __ ] with just the United
States no everywhere we did two seasons
of Gaunt going around the world and now
this next this third season coming up
we're about to do with New York centric
we're gonna do ten episodes tri-state
area show [ __ ] you could go to
Greece without without going to Greece
just go to a story you know you go to
[ __ ] Chinatown you want to go to
[ __ ] Laos we're gonna go to Jackson
Heights take you to [ __ ] Laos
mad locations there's so many different
things all over the [ __ ] place
you know what I mean that's not the
fight like Brooklyn go [ __ ] yes go to
the Russians over there but they got
every [ __ ] food like they break it
down with science up in Brooklyn like
like provinces for sure you know like
provinces are certain things you know so
it's pretty interesting now like I've
been gone from New York for 20 years I
can't imagine what all those areas where
I used to go to cop that people tell me
they pay 2,000 for a [ __ ] box bedroom
up there so where tell me some of your
favorite places to cop East New York
what I was growing up yeah okay I
started you start in there was a church
in the village this was the late
seventies and then I just stayed in
Jersey and bought weed and then the hot
hot spot from like 82 to 85 was anywhere
from 178 to 125th Amsterdam right in
Manhattan I mean that's a [ __ ] hot
spot right now for some that was the
[ __ ] hot spot I mean Washington
Heights has some of the best weed in the
world
Washington Dominicans they got this [ __ ]
man it's called haze
it's called poo day it's a special type
of [ __ ] weed you only get this weed
in Washington nice I've never seen it
anywhere else no one could tell me what
we'd it is no one could tell me where it
came from no one could tell me why who
[ __ ] else has it only these [ __ ]
Dominicans with curly hair they got to
[ __ ] they got that [ __ ] the curly hair
[ __ ] they [ __ ] screaming playing
baseball I love it they got the best
weed and then Webster Avenue in the
Bronx that's a pretty [ __ ] heavy-duty
play I did Jerome I haven't owned the
Bronx oh yeah they came so two
counterpart each other now I'm talking
about 1992 town
apart each other Webster or one of those
streets I may be wrong but one of them
said [ __ ] it if you come to our spots on
Wednesday you buy a bag we'll give you a
joint and that got out so [ __ ] white
kids for and every car coming over from
all five will [ __ ] rich barrows to
buy we cuz that time though those are
the hot spots to buy weed that's a big
deal that's a big deal specialist a
bigger special you know oh when I left
New York there was two types of weed
there was green weed and there was
Buddha that's it
that's it and then some spots mixed them
and they called it the master mix and
then we would go to Staten Island it was
a spot in Staten Island that was all the
times but then that got too crazy you
tell you hold over by machines you wanna
buy machinery sit over there Park over
there we'll be right over what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] [ __ ] Bank [ __ ] but but
then there's the flip side of that where
I used to get coke and knows whether
there was a spot in Brooklyn but I could
go over and buy up to you know four
ounces of coke cash 24 hours a day from
they were there from like 84 to [ __ ]
I would I left in 93 I went back in 93
for a year and they were still there but
the hot hot hot spots the cocaine was
Washington Heights and it was right when
you went right over the bridge as soon
as you got over the bridge you didn't
have to do dick you have to do dick you
just pulled to that right you made the
left and then you shot down humana left
down the street you pulled in you went
upstairs you sat down they had two bags
25 and 35 they gave you a line of each
boom-boom and you went back in your car
if you went back over George Washington
Bridge you should be shot huh
and they should shoot your mother in the
head for being a dumb [ __ ] for having
you because that's basic 101 you don't
do that what you do is you take that car
you hide that cocaine and you go down
Broadway a little bit nice to be a Cuban
spot on about on their 75th up from the
hospital that you park right out then
you go get a little Cuban meal you eat
the Cuban food you get on the West Side
Highway you shoot down you go across the
Lincoln Tunnel and nobody says two words
again you gotta [ __ ] the meal all right
you don't have ten dollars for the
[ __ ] for the Cuban meal stop and get
a hot dog but still take the Lincoln
Tunnel you're saying it's one of the
most underrated things is the [ __ ]
meal after the drug copy nobody
understands them that's the whole [ __ ]
that's the whole thing it's the joyous
to victory even if you go buy a bag of
heroin let's say you're a heroin type of
do cuz I had a brother that was a heroin
type of dude he'd go into those
neighborhoods but he went with the
intention of eating something that would
fuel the heroin high so he would go
skinned pop and make sure it was good
he'd go into his favorite [ __ ] a
Greek restaurant get 22 Malacca
sandwiches and write the bathroom blast
off he even [ __ ] told me he wanted to
get like write a book about listen to
this this this is an 80 this
[ __ ] told me this he looked me
in the eye one day high on heroin he
goes listen man I got an idea for a book
I go what is it he goes what if I wrote
a book about all the best diners but you
could shoot heroin nobody'll bother you
he had it all the way up to Coney Island
because that's how crazy those heroin
dudes go bro they go crazy but he had a
whole four he had a job he was a leak
all those people are functioning a
heroin guy but he would go up and down
that [ __ ] thing and tell me what
places he would go eat order a meal like
a gentleman and he'd go on a bathroom
blast off walk out and [ __ ] light his
t-shirt on fire
but that was it well I then well I left
New York Washington Heights the last
summer I was in New York the Dominicans
were running [ __ ] so heavy up there that
they had thrown a [ __ ] bucket of
spackle from the forth from the roof of
a building and a building inspector
because he tried to bust into these
Dominicans stuff what's the movie of
Wesley Snipes when he takes over the
building in the 80s
New Jack city likes for Dominicans took
over like a [ __ ] two-bedroom
apartment Marsh I swear to God and they
had a lookout up on the roof and the
building inspector came they drew a
bottle a bucket of spackle at him and
that was the end that set off like a
[ __ ] wall and that was it then I
moved to Colorado
good [ __ ] operation going on up damn
it
there are a lot of lookouts a lot of
whistling going on but I heard that New
York is completely different now like
it's not the way like I can still get a
machine gunner for the mortars sure no
kidding me get a [ __ ] m16 right now
you get an m60 right two blocks away
from my house at for the [ __ ] one
morning they got [ __ ] 25 m16s they
are whatever you want in the projects
over there that is crazy [ __ ] they got
[ __ ] guns and never seen before they
got [ __ ] German guns that you [ __ ]
James Bond was using in Goldeneye you
know the little [ __ ] Ruger the little
[ __ ] fancy one who they should
imagine getting shot with that like you
[ __ ] created shot with a [ __ ]
vintage German gun not just regular
projects at the hardest place to smoke a
joint in this country number one place
in New York City
I just [ __ ] light up on the street
you don't give a [ __ ] you I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] either Eddie
what are they gonna do making it [ __ ]
I'm just curious I'm not sure but I
think what are they gonna [ __ ] do
they're gonna come up to you and they're
gonna do what is what are they gonna say
put it out no I'm
I don't know I just [ __ ] do things
until someone asks me to stop nicely and
then I'll figure it out I feel the same
[ __ ] I figured after that even the
San Francisco I sparked [ __ ] where
with a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] people
are adults you know what time it is you
know what time is this distribution we
don't know anyway ten o'clock you know
there's a bad [ __ ] neighborhood I'm
true I can't do it no more
you know like I'm too old man to [ __ ]
around with it
I hide it from you know I'll smoke
outside from my kid you know I'm saying
I won't smoke in the [ __ ] house no no
ya can't [ __ ] your smoke in front of the
kid I feel like you can't do that it's
just ridiculous but then again they see
one on TV doing it what the [ __ ] is a
difference eventually I can't [ __ ]
eventually someday they're gonna say I
don't know when I'll try to [ __ ] tap
out those YouTube things this [ __ ] like
that
so you still dig the cookin I get
inspired when I go to these different
you know countries and places I get
totally inspired to do things and
[ __ ] make things and invent things
and that's just an edge I got over a lot
of you know people and whatever we do I
[ __ ] I really did this for many years
and it's a unique thing thank you very
much this is what this is my origin I
love [ __ ] a lot of instant
gratification I love Vince ting I love
to [ __ ] make something for somebody
presented to them and then watch the
happiness on their face you know I don't
like you when they don't like it I like
it when they like it so I try and make a
base from it's from the heart knowing
you make chicken palm that's in the
[ __ ] heart I could tell when you yes
totally from the [ __ ] heart man I
just
what makes your chicken parm [ __ ]
superb
I want to see that we had the [ __ ]
care that I put into this chicken parm I
pound it down so [ __ ] thin in every
aspect that you're gonna get a crunch on
every corner that's what I like that's
the most important part okay so then I
make it two minutes two minutes I'm a
toe sauce just fry up some [ __ ]
garlic but some dried chilli in there in
the oil can of pureed tomatoes it's over
salt that's it let it rock just let it
sit there no pepper no you know it
doesn't need it at this point
no pepper at this point then you take
the [ __ ] Palio mozzarella cheese
which is a big deal poly poly Oh whole
milk because it melts perfectly no other
cheese melts perfectly I don't know any
other cheese with this they sell it in
string cheese applications they sell it
in logs bricks whatever you want it's
[ __ ] tremendous so you cover the
whole [ __ ] thing you can put sauce on
it real nice cover the whole [ __ ]
thing with the cheese even the areas
where there's no chicken you put cheese
you know just so you get a full blanket
a full quilt of cheese and then you
stick that [ __ ] under the
salamander so it heats from the top also
and you get all those brown crunchy bits
and the cheese is melted like [ __ ]
it's just [ __ ] gorgeous you lift it
up and it's just elastic touch elastic
cheese up and down you [ __ ] bring it
to your mouth you have to [ __ ] hold
the cheese here and rip it a little bit
you know you know when you have to rip
the cheese a little bit it's too much
and you [ __ ] wrap it around it's
phenomenal it's all about the crunch
absolutely it's all about the crunch on
those little corners man system just to
remind you that this was a fried chicken
you have a restaurant now I don't but my
you know the world is my restaurant
I cook everywhere everywhere I can the
world is my restaurant have you ever
cooked not
hi I'm not stoned I'm sure really it
seems it's not fun I like listening to
[ __ ] salsa while I'm [ __ ] I'm
doing my thing while I'm cooking
specifically Frankie's Ruiz one of my
favorites there's nothing like listening
to a good Latin beat while [ __ ]
cooking it makes you cook better you
know what I mean to me it makes me cook
better it's a rhythm it's a rhythm it's
a [ __ ] Afro rhythm with Latin Flair
that you just can't get anywhere else
it's just something else means they
don't make salsa music like you're doing
Puerto Rico and in Cuban just [ __ ]
talked about the two Cuban [ __ ] the
the twin of us a social club my man
Ibrahim Ferrer phenomenal phenomenal
[ __ ] ridiculous all right P you know
what's crazy I look at you and it's like
you have your ethnic roots but you took
advantage in New York City to the max
you took a little bit from every little
aspect icily you enjoy every [ __ ]
flavor and that's the beauty of coming
from that area right up you know like
that's like when I first moved to New
York from Cuba I used to have a beef
every day we really the Haitian right
this little black guru the Haitian I'm
gonna think about it years later when I
was in the third grade I used to have
beef over the age you and you pick up
this certain flavor you get to meet
Jewish kids and you talk to them for a
while and let's pretend like you go play
tennis were done and they don't get
hired but that's good you can just go
play tennis with them yeah but some of
the weekends you play hoops with a bunch
of Puerto Rican dudes who get high and
they carry knives but then on Sunday is
your [ __ ] right you're hanging out
with your girlfriend's family and
they're [ __ ] Russian mm-hmm you get
this flavor you grew up with this
certain now
like for me it was like Greek mm-hmm
Italian you know Greek Italian for sure
that's a queen specialty right there
yeah you know Greek Italian [ __ ]
Puerto Rican [ __ ] my uncle my uncle
was the super of the building that
Christopher Walken grew up in Astoria
his [ __ ] parents lived in the
building you know like we used to walk
to Steinway Street
I had [ __ ] Jamaica Avenue five
minutes from me
I had Flushing Main Street well the
Asians were right near me you know I had
[ __ ] Forest Hill is where it was like
a nice weird enclave of like [ __ ]
ethnicities and like there's older Jews
and young people's like a lot of weird
[ __ ] going on there like a little bit of
a [ __ ] Queens nightlife I just you
see a lot of [ __ ] man you see the foot I
remember [ __ ] one of the first people
that introduced me to like loving to be
in the kitchen as a as a [ __ ] man
from Ecuador named Rigoberto you know
you used to work for my pops in the
restaurant used to call me a little fat
[ __ ]
I loved it he was like make me giggle a
little fat piece of [ __ ] haha like it
was funny you look gordito you go
[ __ ] you fat [ __ ]
and then I would see him chopping up the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] parsley he's like a
little kid on the matter 1up money one
like I'm [ __ ] six years old so I'm
like giggling and [ __ ] I love that my
life when you chill in the [ __ ]
kitchen with Mexicans you start hating
like your own people and like they start
talking [ __ ] you about [ __ ] white
people and [ __ ] it's true
you start hating yourself
[ __ ] well you're very Viva Mexico you're
very interested dude in that facet that
I could tell that you wish man Queens
made me that's what this is this is
Queens as the as the epicenter of all
this [ __ ] it's very very very eclectic I
think that the last time they did some
sort of study they found out that
there's more ethnicities in the borough
of Queens that there is anywhere else in
this world that's great I always thought
it was Brooklyn no good I always thought
it was I always thought it was [ __ ]
Brooklyn Brooklyn became [ __ ] [ __ ]
great crazy book now [ __ ] everyone from
Ohio [ __ ] I don't even know the thing
about you that I see that he could his
restaurant would be so off the hook
because you wouldn't know what you were
really gonna get that night that's why I
[ __ ] love you man you really do get
me he would wake up in the morning and
go you know what bro
I feel like a [ __ ] fish greek-style
and then you know but these employees
like but wait a second you know mr.
bronsen it should be this is a dis team
restaurant that's why I would be hard
you wouldn't know what you were gonna
cook till that day you might come in and
want two eggs of bacon that's not on the
menu no [ __ ] it's a Spanish for
tatata
with asparagus and goat cheese of woof
Adele [ __ ] baked all over it with a
little sauce yeah [ __ ] hate goat
cheese told me list not only one way to
look at [ __ ] makes me [ __ ] decide
I love a lot of things in this world but
goat cheese I should [ __ ] taste like
straight you know what you selfie
[ __ ]
yes that's nothing I don't give a [ __ ]
of people get drunk people get pissed if
we go there when you said Palio cheese
our almost
because they have it out here today I
think they do
cuz that's me I talked to some people
out here and they never [ __ ] I was
like yo no you know about paleo cheese
in their leg no no what
hotel bar brother oh come on oh yes
[ __ ] sit in my freezer right here
stick a hot italian bread back in the
old days and the bronx is done you go
home you get that old stick of [ __ ]
old tub of butter before they do this is
when altered on strong unsalted mother
salted if you're walking on ice you
might as well dance if you're gonna kill
that heart
kill that heart would [ __ ] style saw
oh my god I would [ __ ] kill I didn't
like that I like the hotel bar like I
would get the bar that's how old-school
I was I get the Italian bread and like
cut and just put [ __ ] butter on it
from the age of maybe 10 to like 13 I
did this and one day somebody's like dog
you know how bad that is for you doesn't
matter
life is literally about bread and I
would eat the guts but nobody would eat
I would eat those [ __ ] guts I would
heat them up with butter and let the
butter melting for the guts ah [ __ ]
delicious delicious that's phenomenal
stuff man is letting butter melt into
bread in any facet any capacity is where
it's at
you let that [ __ ] bagel sit with the
butter for just a little bit you don't
eat it right away you get every bite
soaked and you face the salty tsoukalos
it's something special even the most
simplest [ __ ] meathead thing could be
[ __ ] mind-blowing you know like bagel
and butter a few [ __ ] toast that
bagel right and you let that butter sit
on the bagel just enough that's 52 stars
52 [ __ ] stars Michelin New York
Times wherever you want to [ __ ] do 50
best restaurants in the world
just give me a bagel with butter or some
simple man
work with a want but what's your
favorite kind of bagel my favorite bagel
is from utopia bagels and Queens utopia
bagels and Queens and [ __ ] Bayside
they do a bagel that has a hard crunch
on it it's still fluffy in the middle
which I really enjoy
and my favorite one happens to be a
sesame when you toast that sesame it's
like you're [ __ ] it's like you're
putting [ __ ] on my mouth what do you
put on a butter cream cheese I don't see
they put too much cream cheese they
[ __ ] put it do I have an issue with
New York City [ __ ] bagel Rees they
put weight they put a thick [ __ ]
thing of cream cheese and you go to open
it's all over your face
so although video you don't even know if
that tastes good it doesn't you needed a
little a thin layer of it I like to go
with the butter soaked in or I get one
slice of mono restaurant for breakfast
and they give me toast with two pieces
of butter next to it you put the [ __ ]
it's logic you've gotta put the [ __ ]
butter on the toast in the comes on you
in the middle don't know that [ __ ]
middle there's no butter I gotta get the
[ __ ] butter and open and paddled it
with a knife bang this raucous rock hard
you can't [ __ ] schmear it you know
that [ __ ] drives me crazy but we're
gonna do this is America today that's
what they do I remember being a kid and
going to the Bronx and getting a corn
muffin and they cut it in half and
soaked it in butter huh and put it on
the [ __ ] grill on the griddle
god damn
short-order cook in the [ __ ] City man
we had you Evie my [ __ ] grandfather
we used to go to [ __ ] restaurants
used to make my mother take the [ __ ]
bread he would make my mother open her
pocketbook say put the [ __ ] bread put
the butter in the bag take good napkins
take the ketchup and we did everything
everything came from elsewhere coffee
lids the coffee things that you put on
the coffee to hold it where gets too hot
you took the flames the sleeves [ __ ]
that's we had trays from McDonald's
eating trays
because like my grandfather would eat
his [ __ ] lenders bagel because he was
in West Palm Beach he still needed his
bagel lenders it's a disgusting bagel
but it works
lenders [ __ ] bagel a little bit of
Philadelphia Cream Cheese out of
McDonald's try this man all those baked
Lay's little bagels like Noah's Bagels
when you're in a [ __ ] rush and you're
an airport 7 the morning you smoked 82
Joyce in that before Noah's Bagels work
mm-hmm
it works you just got a coach and gonna
get cream cheese with Turkey the slice
of tomato that's a nice one oh my god
little turkeys nice I love the turkey in
the moat Turkey well hello poppy seed Oh
obviously poppy seed is another one time
it's a tremendous favor
obviously the only problem is it gets in
their teeth after brushing teeth yes
that's what you want that's what you
want I like picking my teeth I look
forward to picking my teeth I [ __ ] I
can [ __ ] work wonders with this
corner right here yeah give me a [ __ ]
thing from the cigarette give me
anything so with a little [ __ ] thing
and I'm digging in you put some Tony
Bennett on the ears just gonna sit there
dog can't [ __ ] trying to picture that
type of [ __ ] night lazy gentleman man
Action Bronson in the house rolling
joints like a [ __ ] that's like it has
a like a cartel member
[Music]
you
I need another star you know what give
me another [ __ ] Bob peanut butter
awesome
those [ __ ] stars is delicious -
really government take good they take it
to a certain place look at leas evening
19 another mashallah particle blows
easily those [ __ ] mushrooms a Fugazi
I'm disappointed I'm sorry we've been
getting good mushrooms the last couple
times there's one dude that shows up to
the shows he grinds them up and put some
THC chocolate huh they take it to a
different level
are you [ __ ] getting to the point
where you can't have an open your
[ __ ] mouth but yeah ah no I still
function okay cuz I like taking the
mushrooms from the your how about [ __ ]
your face is paralyzed you know I can't
go home by now I listen if I cannot walk
in my house I can't watch my nobody
[ __ ] know I can't walk in the house
you [ __ ] have like I like watching
the nature Channel that's one of those
[ __ ] things on know last time we I
was on [ __ ] mushrooms I was with my
girl and we were watching the [ __ ]
the goats
you know those [ __ ] goats that climb
up the mountain and then they cut to a
close-up of this [ __ ] goats face I
almost [ __ ] lost my mind I lost my
[ __ ] mind I [ __ ] jumped off the
couch it was out of my face
it was amazing why do you watch scary
things when you're high what's not scary
I guess it wasn't scary I just didn't
know that they were gonna cut to a
close-up of a [ __ ] goat on the
mountain his face looked so crazy you
could see every crevasse you can see
every [ __ ] vein pulsating pretty much
main stone and just seeing a bug like a
goat on the mountain as you're driving
that's what I mean if and they're
[ __ ] tiptoeing on the side of the
mountain you know I mean like it's
really next level you know it's [ __ ]
nuts you have like 10 shows on [ __ ]
violent like we live Iceland
oh my and they're all we what tough for
you have a show called [ __ ] I mean
that this is where we're going
it's mm that's why I love Iceland
because they [ __ ] take that they're
living in today's world at least they
try to live a [ __ ] today yeah
man I think that these are the only
people that you know that would take
that tears of naming the show who [ __ ]
you know they allow me to name that
would I want to name it so they went
with it
[ __ ] love that [ __ ] they love
scream what's the first thing you say we
[ __ ] say something good off [ __ ] this
I do we know either [ __ ] or [ __ ] for
some reason you equate [ __ ] with being
disgusting but [ __ ] sometimes it's
amazing depends to pay exactly it really
depends it depends depends the situation
now you know I got a call one day and
they said hey man we were interested in
you doing hot ones and I said what is
and they said to show about people
thought I need hot wings and I didn't I
didn't know what to think
I turned it on I saw what's his name he
wouldn't need them and that's all I turn
yours on and it was very interesting you
got a friend on there mm-hmm big body
but the most interesting [ __ ] things
that I know why I would love you was
because that you he wasn't ask you about
sorry the TV chefs the chefs or
something like that and he responded
well bow before you even ask me that
this Japanese to better be number one on
that [ __ ] list and he was but he you
know and you started dropping names of
different chefs that you like so I'm
gonna had heard you know the Mario
Batali is the popular ones and some guys
even no [ __ ] existed who's your
favorite chef who was the Asian
gentleman this this is someone that
inspired me it was a show called Yan can
cook you ever seen that [ __ ] back in the
day was on PBS [ __ ] guy big smile
just always teaching [ __ ] Americans
how to make Chinese food very like
gently he was amazing like one of my
earliest memories I don't [ __ ] know
why I like it is for dick like crazy
[ __ ] I love [ __ ] Yan can cook that's
why he was your favorite chef yeah now
you're not just he's not he's next he's
just on some next-level [ __ ] man you
know he's on some [ __ ] at all he will
teach people he's how to cook Chinese
that's it easy ways to cook Chinese
[ __ ] food
easy easy easy I love Jacques pépin also
because in the kitchen where I worked we
had a little [ __ ] TV we'd watch
soccer
I'd watch baseball I'd watch the [ __ ]
novellas did be one that we always watch
all the time and [ __ ] and Tebow alone
you know that one
no they fighting the [ __ ] guy told me
is the is one of the Mexican actors that
he's like 70 years old but he got the
[ __ ] [ __ ] will you pump the ball you
know so that's how he identified him he
has the [ __ ] who pumps the ball wee-wee
has to pump the bullet and [ __ ] get
hard but that's where we used to I used
to watch PBS when I did brunch you know
I would work brunch I come in at 10:00
a.m.
[ __ ] Martin Yan ji Jacques pépin
would be on all day then the infomercial
for the golden for the golden oldies you
know you know when they have the revival
[ __ ] things and they sell the [ __ ]
compilation they put on like the same
exactly a second of each song yeah it's
the same people it's crazy it's amazing
that's how you go you know I didn't get
into cooking shows the first guy that I
was that I got you you know the only
reason why you stop and watch the
cooking shows cuz you're either a fat
[ __ ] or you stalled or you're both right
when you're both you say [ __ ] it let me
watch what this [ __ ] whipping
up and it was the Italian guy who really
did great because he even got NBC to
give him a [ __ ]
sitcom that dude what was his name
Rocco DiSpirito you talking about no no
they talk about Batali
no no not mr. Batali the [ __ ] Italian
dude kind of lost his hair they gave him
a show on a band let me see it a [ __ ]
sitcom that's how popular he got this is
98 97 in Italian yeah yeah you said he
was one of your that you liked him
chef something and but then you spoke
about like the one I always watch and I
was always interested in because we're
sort of from the same neighborhood is no
reservations
Bourdain you know yes it was very
interesting what you said how he mixed
both worlds that's the kind of show I
would like to do man he's a [ __ ] what
the we'd go to cop the wagon in the
illegal labor hood and that's what the
[ __ ] we do
that's the gen I've been on I've been on
TV going uptown my cousin jumped out
bought 40 dimes of [ __ ] Hayes from
uptown he pulls it out of his nuts
he's on mushrooms we're in the [ __ ]
back at the uber we stopped right before
we get back onto the highway because we
already have the joint roll we already
have the Blum rolled we stop right there
at the truck
it's called latina it's the cootchie
free tow truck the free to toss so
everything is fried oh then they get the
[ __ ] oreja they got the lengua they
got got best not going down they got
whatever you want but they got one
Dominican specialty called chimi
chimichurri
it's like a [ __ ] Oh like a pounded
patty like a burger type of thing
flavored with oregano garlic oh that's
not song chopped cabbage Mayo ketchup on
it on a toasted roll it's like [ __ ]
it's like insane man that's the ritual
every time you go uptown the car pays
you smoke on the way to get the [ __ ] for
sure on the FDA you take the FDR because
you that's the freeway
FDR boom right there 170 to make the
left then
you go get your [ __ ] come back roll it
up get the chee me back on the highway
same way Grand Central now because they
don't have the [ __ ] tolls in place
you good to go
we'll walk back home we used to do the
smoking tour this was one of the my
favorite things in life to do is going
on a tour I go on the [ __ ] tour of
New York City smoking as many blunts as
we can never having to get off the
highway
circling going through Brooklyn going to
Queens going to Brooklyn go through
Queens go to Brooklyn go it's all good
see sights it's beautiful you get all
[ __ ] Brighton Beach you go get some
[ __ ] Russian food go to the bathhouse
let them hit you with a [ __ ] tree in
the back you know let me say some well I
first came out here the medical
marijuana thing was starting to grow you
know it dawned on me one day I'm like
wait a second come on the [ __ ] like
me half the high is going to cop it and
going back that was for me that was in
mind the way I was raised like that
that's how I like to yeah that was a
dude in the neighborhood no no my
throats already [ __ ] up from the six
shows in [ __ ] San Francisco we can
but you have local dude yeah he was be
was going to the city to get into so one
day you said [ __ ] that what am i doing
my life anyway go get it myself and in
the meantime you know what why are you
waiting you saw a separate hotdog but he
also made up he made those little steaks
and bobs and he give you a white bread a
piece of white bread on top of this yeah
well alright that's all the [ __ ]
don't know about that that's my whole
name that's that's I put that [ __ ] in my
oh my god I put the [ __ ] bread on the
top of the thing that's one of my new oh
my god you know you get the [ __ ]
kebab and then they put two loves
Italian bread on the top of the stick
and you walk away $2 you get you some
lemon on it
mm I would leave I would eat four or
five of them $2 apiece my god and then
the guy would maybe he makes a piece of
bread and [ __ ] maybe if I was a good boy
he'd give me a piece of bread it was
those those were the things that made
you cop the adventure you were doing by
yourself well I would take Lee with me
you know you never just went into the
city Lee and bought a bag of reefer and
ran back you always went to somewhere to
eat
there was a Carvel close to the to the
time for the bridge would say we would
go get Cuban food and then walk to the
car Val and I'm the walk to the cars out
we smoked a joint walk to the car Val
got a black and white shake or a
chocolate shake but done now we're
talking expert level Nabokov and that
work sprinkles with color with colored
sprinkles and whipped cream and then we
go to a movie theater on the corner
there 181 and Broadway they used to be
like a triple feature you turned it into
an adventure copy I could never even
dream we're just going into a store
getting three joint and driving home the
whole thing was driving back with the
weed in the trunk going you know like
bellowing or smoking the whole way take
a chance Columbus did [ __ ] let's go
so that was part of the high was driving
back with that half ounce under your
seat thinking about that [ __ ] chicken
parmesan you're gonna make a [ __ ] that's
at the house already you know your
girlfriend's watching the sauce this
[ __ ] like Paulie what's-his-name way huh
what's-his-name and Goodfellas he told
the girl watch the sauce you're just
going after around the corner that's
what it was now I like this concept like
I like this concept of I got two places
where I cop and ten in the morning I
know they both told you get into this to
the world of leads no because he knows
yeah he knows I'm a professional the
weed store visit n I'm there a 1000 and
bothering the
do 9:55 think I'm [ __ ] kidding you I
want to be the first customer today I
want no misunderstanding and these
[ __ ] all soft they get to work
late so I [ __ ] them all up the one place
they're on point the Russians they're on
point Jack they get that a quarter to
ten of the attention they got those hot
girls working in there so sometimes I'd
dip over there that's such a terrible
hmm
but yeah I go there at five ten in the
morning I want no [ __ ] drama you just
drive over now and going there's nowhere
to stop didn't there's no journey my
favorite thing about living in New York
City was that you know what problem you
know what action does I got to do some
[ __ ] tomorrow 9:00 in the morning and
you do too don't you I get me too
what about I swing by the house about
corner [ __ ] 8:00
we smoke a joint it too and we swing by
the Bronx gonna slice and go to that
Carvel next to him I'll have you home by
[ __ ] 9:15 that is my world
we don't nobody we got nowhere to go
ahead there we gotta go to Huntington
Beach to get a [ __ ] milkshake or
something like that
thanks to [ __ ] I was there in 19
hours back by the time you get back in
early morning in high no more you like
done I'm done
that was my thing when I lived on the
East Coast was let's take a ride over
that smoke a joint on the way there eat
something
then you got that after [ __ ] done a
joint which means you go home early and
go to sleep
and that be new loot time nobody bothers
you knows I just smoked [ __ ] that's
it this has to there has to be like
non-stop smoking
whenever we'd hang out now stop smoking
with the boys
sometime you talking about the thrill of
the cop we cop from as many different
people as possible you know what I mean
the good stuff sometimes we go smoking
the whole house you know what I mean
while the girls are working sometimes
you know thing
what happened in the whorehouse I know
he was that yeah but I'm gonna show is
the whorehouse set [ __ ] there's so many
[ __ ] houses they used to be the thirty
dollar houses still I don't know anymore
but they used to be $30 $40 Hollis like
crazy [ __ ] all over the place he's one
of our holiday all around the world all
around the world take you she'll take it
up the [ __ ] [ __ ] pink but she'll
stop you like real life it was it was a
wild thing
it was a wild scene how much do you tip
I don't know man it was you know like I
just hung out and smoked you'll be at
the doctor every day for a year knowing
you'll have [ __ ] corn pudding all over
your [ __ ] [ __ ] ballsack I went to
the $26 one also I was the discounted
one Doug when I was growing up there was
a 10:40 club it was $10 it was 999
attacks 10:40 and they still have it
supposing it's not 10:40 anymore 40 they
just kept the [ __ ] name and [ __ ] 26th
up bro when I was a kid when I was 13
there was these two [ __ ] brothers
that went into the city every weekend I
got their dick sucked like $12 it was 19
and be like 1976 haha and these do you
feel young if I was 13 the one brother
was 13 and the other guy was like 12 but
he didn't have it all together see
whatever he would do whatever the
brother with talent and [ __ ] and every
Monday at school they would have a story
where they go they would leave on
Saturday mornings by themselves to go
get to go until the Bronx or Queens they
would go to these spots and for $10 the
chicks would take them in the back and
wash their dick with a bucket sucked a
dick and lick their balls they would
come back with a thousand stories the
thing is that you know I I would
definitely pay to get my dick wash with
the bucket
like that's [ __ ] that seems like a nice
amenity get dirty but now that we don't
want to scuzzbucket
when I was gonna say is that one of my
favorite things in life is the nuance of
how someone explains when someone is a
little [ __ ] mental
you said he doesn't have it all together
you know there's just a lot of ways that
you could say it that's very comical
what if you want me to say the truth he
was half [ __ ] but I don't want to
say that I mean no but that's what I
mean oh yeah he's a dog together they
work you just love it
they were cuba's that name was Juan
Alberto our week one was the brain of
the operation Alberto was very lazy I
like Rocky's wife type show like yeah
boss whatever you're saying like that
type SH I like that and they would come
back on Mondays and just drop knowledge
on us and our [ __ ] jaws were dropped
we were barely getting titties these
guys were going deep in the jungle of
sex getting their dick sucked and washed
and they were telling listed there the
first person who told men around the
world when he was 13 he knows from 15
now to give you around the world I'm
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
can you explain something I have sex
with my girlfriend laying on our sides
for some reason [ __ ] terrible
when I wasn't [ __ ] like early in high
school we used to lay on our sides for
some reason so I didn't wake anyone up
it was terrible sex oh no that's how you
doing no but then you know then you
[ __ ] no one's home you still going
nuts but then laying on the side sex was
wild
but you figured I'd give her somebody a
stabbing at the beach yeah after a while
you figure it out we go family I'm sorry
I'm just confused about the the dick
washing are you saying like there's no
hand to wash your dick they wash you
dick erotically they take the to a
bucket well they get hot water with a
sponge with soap on it
and they stretch it out for you and they
wash your balls is [ __ ] then they dry it
off E and then they they put a condom on
it and they [ __ ] suck you know on
okay I think it might be a [ __ ] used
condom that's what uh yeah you never
know they might be saving money you
don't know they got them hanging upside
down in the back and [ __ ] like [ __ ]
photos [ __ ] hand job she comes in
with a [ __ ] condom without a wrapper
if you think if she loses she goes this
I think this one will fit your [ __ ] dog
I didn't know those things are still
even though sister anymore what can I
ask you Bronson can you get dumplings I
will is it okay to get like meat
dumplings or they can all dumplings are
cat dumplings and I can't I kiss it okay
to get dumplings where anyway yeah you
have another one [ __ ] things
dumplings I think it's pretty safe to
get dumped in a certain place I had some
[ __ ] tremendous ones today I had a
wonton soup
I had a wonton soup like I had never had
a wonton soup before we're at this place
that he took me to a career to get
tumblings you should look for the stray
cat so there's no strike has good listen
this is the potato back you given me the
dude on your block that you know I was
telling these people you have a seven
syscall these poor kids they got labels
you know every kid's got a label Maile
when you meet them really hi this is
Henry and then when the kid go go go on
and play don't look you straight in the
face name the Sadd and he has you know
PTSD and all this [ __ ] [ __ ] Nam when
I grew up either you were a [ __ ]
[ __ ] are you alright are you a dumb
[ __ ] with heart yes see if you grew up
in New York City you grew up with dudes
that would dumb [ __ ] but they had a lot
of heart let's see yeah you had heart
they had hard my men oh my god my man
Phil Annunziata from Queens
he was the sweetest do didn't have it
all together like you say he's [ __ ]
brute strength you can hit a [ __ ]
baseball 450 feet but he can't [ __ ]
tell you 2+2 you know but he's an
amazing for the store the [ __ ] hands
of rocks he's one of those guys he's the
plumber now he's just a great guy you
know those are one of those guys you
know you still talk to a lot of the guys
to the neighborhood you grew up with I
see them a lot well you laugh about that
sighs he's [ __ ] all that stars
killing yes no I got him looking at me
[ __ ] you have to bought some pink
floyd--
yeah take one more one more
take one mortal take one game you look
good for did you eat the whole trust me
take one more yeah well more that's good
take one more Michigan what's going on
with you over there you want one more
just eat it man just eat it just eat it
eat it eat it it's vegan
eat it yo bro we [ __ ] kidding me right
now can you [ __ ] eat it please [ __ ]
one for me yeah no you just a [ __ ]
gummy you just nibbled on one of them
[ __ ] points of the star
eat that's for that I don't like the way
you're eating the gummy please please
you're freaking me out
it's crazy please the way you're eating
the gummy is making me nauseous can you
please stop oh yeah I have a give you
leave for a month you'll straight the
bus yeah you don't get I would love to
have leave for a couple of days he sees
Leo he's phenomenal he has Leslie poison
his father with what he picks the worst
restaurants because he doesn't want to
listen to people so he goes on Yelp
reviews and I try to talk to him and his
girlfriend loves you he loves you so
before they go on a date like a week
before they plan it and they both go on
Yelp and they look at the whole menu
from the Yelp and they take what people
say you know honestly and then he never
goes back so I asked him how it was I'm
discussing with you I'm telling you you
have no idea what I got a little that's
not the only time I got a rush but yeah
but every restaurant is tied you use
Yelp one worse than the valley eat the
[ __ ] thing bro eat the whole thing
Rose eat the whole [ __ ] thing you see
market are you fake chewing keep it
funky with me are you fake chewing I
know the tricks you telling me I don't
know these tricks
leave is it sound familiar only [ __ ]
does periscopes yeah I used to start can
I go Instagram live right now you do
whatever the [ __ ] you want
[ __ ] hope I go to bathroom anyway I
can barely cook it takes me 2 hours to
do a 45-minute blue apron I'm gonna make
stars
oh my god I've gone through two parts
about your new up your new album again
remind the people listen to me we live
at the [ __ ] at the [ __ ]
mecca we have the cathedral right now
with my man we shall we Coco Diez and
what the [ __ ] is your name Lee what my
aunt Li Wang saya saya yes sir and least
Siot yo man this has been fun this has
been [ __ ] ridiculous Joey went to go
take a [ __ ] piss Cup oh you went to
go take a joke Piscopo real quick I
don't even have another [ __ ] joint
rolled man I'm gonna have to [ __ ] set
this down on the [ __ ] wheat thing was
so I could roll more you've been one of
the first people to like hang with Joey
I'm gonna text on the soggy level hangar
Joey
those [ __ ] stars are those mushrooms
dr. Daisy the stars the stars on
[ __ ] fires or what the [ __ ] you
think you're dealing with uncle Joey
here [ __ ] aah straight from the
Voodoo Lounge trying to [ __ ] keep it
down all hours of the night I'm saying
is he stoned to the gills stars
mushrooms the [ __ ] pipe of death
we got the mule the little mule the
medium you we got the flying Jew in the
[ __ ] house
it's all over but the shouting you
understand me and it's just Monday night
that's how we kick off the [ __ ]
week coming to huh that's [ __ ] three
weeks away I'm talking about ten eight
[ __ ] we're here right now
[ __ ] live and in color [ __ ]
football uncle Joey Action Bronson
swingin dick talkin about [ __ ] smoking
weed eating food and how not to get in
trouble that's the best [ __ ] thing
spooning your [ __ ] don't just sit there
I'm gonna give you like five [ __ ]
minutes of this [ __ ] you can have five
minutes of this let's see if you can see
both of us here so nobody not gonna see
what the [ __ ] you know I'm sitting there
yeah none of my so this guy went from
being a chef to being a rapper right I'm
like that's a unique thing and also in
like wait a second people usually go
from prison rapid I'm starving the rapid
so what's the it was tremendous I don't
[ __ ] know man it just happens [ __ ]
just happens sometimes when it's meant
to happen I don't know you know I'm just
[ __ ]
this is a chance brother I did a groove
you know what something a door closed
and you opened up another one well they
that's what life is about that's
probably the best way I've ever heard it
explained that you've explained it
better than I've you know I've talked
about that before but you just [ __ ]
broke it down right there I took a
chance
I [ __ ] something clicked you're right
that's what happened [ __ ] which would
be a really American drinks without even
dreaming it really you just woke up one
morning and said what Liz I like what
these guys are doing I may be able to
add something to this huh it's also
going bad it's really [ __ ] crazy how
you know I'm trying to write this thing
right now I'm thinking the other day I
got into comedy how I was locked up you
know you know it took me about a year
and a half something made me go down
there and then something made me [ __ ]
stick it out you know and here we are 20
something years later but here we [ __ ]
it all you know we're not locked up or
[ __ ] with Action Bronson Lisa I got
you on a Monday night Detroit Motor City
diseases star [ __ ]
you didn't fake it I am I'm telling you
this damn [ __ ] I am goodness
gracious look at that why'd you lie
clean up he didn't make you look cooler
leaned back down grab your [ __ ]
little baby balls I'm sorry yo he's one
of the best [ __ ] tools ever I'm sorry
for giving you a hard time right now
about your baby bulls you knows he know
what's happening next alive from the
[ __ ] Bronx live from the
[ __ ] Bronx damn Lee what was
hidden him what was your name on the
show he was on the music this is Mark
[ __ ] - Jesus he used to be in the
band called making the band he oh he was
in one of the best bands ever not let me
keep it funky if man was if he'll here's
a break for you
your man was in vlg you remember dlg
he'll look dlg up right now your man was
in dlg just lost a little bit of weight
you're the man
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] willow school bond for
you that's how we have to do it here on
the [ __ ] Monday night you know I'm
saying
start the [ __ ] week grab your balls
it's all over - shot [ __ ] beast
I love you [ __ ] stay black it's
a beautiful day to be alive
always ocean is a unique [ __ ] podcast
all right let me get some shout out so I
got you here [ __ ] Michael Gabbar
Sergio Tigers showed up with some boxing
gloves I got a mail them Zack Sprayberry
Patrick Samoa Caleb Angie Matt Martinez
captain come back Mike Davis
Ricky G and what I do don't forget
Saturday I'm at the [ __ ] Ice
House and then the following week I'm at
the Ontario in Prague so we ain't
[ __ ] around I'm saying
number two I'm happy you [ __ ]
drove you didn't go through the nine
hour delay you know that had to go up
there but it you know what man I got to
tell you something I wasn't pissed off
at all like when I got up there the show
was canceled I pushed it the Sunday I
went to my room I wash my [ __ ] I rolled
the joint I went outside I went for a
little walk
I got something [ __ ] I teamed up with
him Delaware like at midnight talked to
him a little bit they had an expresso
machine the [ __ ] coffee every
floor I made like a triple expression
with midnight one upstairs smoked
another number in another star and long
all that came on I was
good [ __ ] there's a win
you don't listen when you're no when
you're in your house you got vice land
well you know hotel sometimes they did
this [ __ ] hotel had versus the
[ __ ] is that
oh wait I know that I know that Channel
versus was on for what became something
else they never changed the logo it
still had [ __ ] verses on I was a
shock then they had no HBO and no
Showtime but that's something else I
don't know what the [ __ ] they're listen
I don't give a [ __ ] at eight o'clock I
was in on stage anyway so whatever stars
and stars something [ __ ] goofy
something goofy [ __ ] but every night
that's what keeps me alive man is those
lawn orders and you the front like that
you could go into one like at that
25-minute mark and usually saw it so you
know the plot and [ __ ] so I gives you
some time to go downstairs to the
vending machine and get a couple of
snacks to hold your for late-night and
[ __ ] like some Doritos little [ __ ] I
always get their menu or the dog those
[ __ ] those the cheese nachos the one
you stoned and those ones with the chip
nacho chili flavor what are those
beginner Ito's dog hooked on it love
what TV are you really
I know but I just like you know like you
say Lauren order I used to [ __ ] do
CSI like that I would watch any CSI
Miami New York Vegas [ __ ] Zimbabwe
whatever I didn't watch New Yorkers I
audition with the Peru's
I won all the way the producers on this
show and [ __ ] Caruso put the kibosh
know that was Miami I'm talking about oh
[ __ ] Gary Sinise told you no no wasn't
Gary Sinise what is he
you know what happened where the [ __ ]
was it at that time that Fishburne at
that time it was Gary Sinise see but
what happened was that the initial pilot
had a bigger cruel
mmm they had me working in the thing as
like you know go get this like a big
dummy do it never [ __ ] we're in the
[ __ ] lab yeah the lab episode I could
have been kind of crazy you in the foyer
crime lab yeah it's like me actually yo
hold on I'm tellin the [ __ ] presses
this is a joke this was a good no idea
there's just you in a [ __ ] for you as
a [ __ ] crime in a crime lab now would
be crazy crazy [ __ ] ridiculous
he'll be [ __ ] next level like like the
dude was to do from The Odd Couple that
went on to make a [ __ ] show that he
became even more popular for summer by
that he was an autopsy dude not like I
know knowing an autopsy dude what type
of audition like the [ __ ] overnight
[ __ ] morgue I how you say [ __ ] I
still grew up with a dude who had a
funeral parlor you know I used to go to
the city and pick up the [ __ ] bodies
with him from the airport when they
would die in Miami no [ __ ] thing
that's a [ __ ] up job but if you're
looking for a career and you don't want
to join the army it's one year and when
you come out you make on a grand a year
and after like driving no [ __ ] has a
job a cinema a funeral director the
whole thing you [ __ ] dress him up to
Holt and cut their fingernails hold my
hair
a little bit more than hundred grand to
do that let's say you let's say you like
the kid I would be a friends with he
what do you call it
outsource you got the whole process no
they don't so it's a you died in that
plant you died your family came down and
they said are one of you Thursday
through Saturday on Wednesday night a
guy would come [ __ ] arms what
surprise
my arms are numb no what's that process
for embalming they do the whole
embalming process they drain your blood
they break your spine
Oh God they [ __ ] you know do a bunch
of put them on the ground because they
might pop up doing the dancing that's
Michael Jackson Thriller comes on that's
why you play do a bunch of things for
them guys I could be wrong with your
ideas back like when you're on why you
have to break the back because they
might pop Polly oh because of the
[ __ ] muscle - rigor mortis like in
the end like in the old school if you
talk to your grandparents they give you
Dominican Puerto Rican Cuban in those
days when you died with you can take it
or you know Paula no they put you in a
suit and they put you in the living room
for a few days until you started
stinking and people would just come over
and start drinking but from time to time
my hand would pop up and then when it
was time to bury him dog three [ __ ]
gorillas couldn't pull the hand down so
they would have to break the [ __ ] arm
or saw it saw the [ __ ] thing
and from the family there's thousands of
thousands after during there's one hope
they didn't try think about it there
were like how does everyone do this
no they just because you don't know when
your head's gonna pop up you don't know
the listen all I know is that one time
somebody was dead for a few hours
and when the people came to pick up the
body I was there when they picked that
person up and put him on the stretcher
in the last fart came on their ass as
they walk into rego
where's the heavy [ __ ] duty you it's
just not like sewage like they had died
like this was it they were dead you know
I was laying like when and it wasn't
like funny nobody it was outside nobody
laughed we were just and the person
dropped bro and awesomely that they
tried to resuscitate the person and the
person was dead when they picked him up
I was about 19 when they picked him up
you could hear the body do that last
reel and it's just that has to go
somewhere so they got a drain all that
thing goes do a thousand things but
probably think that do would would do
like three or four of those bodies at
night is about a hundred of body oh it
tastes like 40 minutes you just go like
I said break their spine drain their
blood they do a couple other through
this this the eyeballs you know whatever
that's why they used to say don't ever
mark that on your [ __ ] license that
you want to donate your [ __ ] because
they won't even let you [ __ ] die
they'll cut you up before you dead they
just don't know another episode about
that with the do from what a feeling
what I'm feeling 1984 about the dancer
girl he plays the doctor Flashdance he
plays the doctor that [ __ ] cut up a
woman before she died because he got an
internship of that Hospital for to make
a million dollars a year when they had a
show up with a human heart it's [ __ ]
dirty world out there Lisa Annie I'm
saying
how you feeling we think I couldn't
anymore they don't do that yes they do
even take your name off never know when
those [ __ ] people might use it how you
feeling my brother I can't I look at you
dog and I know
going you had never live outside New
York City come on not even really
[ __ ] knew yes you [ __ ] know me
like the back of my [ __ ] I feel your
violence your full hundred and fifty
percent to anything you know and I might
even talk about the hassle if five
minutes from Queens if I don't live in
Queens I have to live right there on
that water or else I'm not happy you
know I still have to drive through the
same neighborhood every day I still have
to take the same route myself just take
the same route every day you know I feel
like I'm just a [ __ ] I'm a product of
where I am I don't know I'm like that
the [ __ ] things that grow from the
[ __ ] ground why you [ __ ] laughing
over there I hope it's because you're
looking at a picture after that my
[ __ ] metaphors you're actually not
even listening to me right good fun in
the 70s there is a disco song there was
an old disco song that he used to be and
it was like kind of weird song overview
this and fellow lyrics she made a lot of
sense and it was called you're a native
New Yorker mm-hmm listening time it was
just on di dad I'm serious
studio 54 so I was listening to it a
couple weeks ago came on and it was like
me like I could you know when I came
from Cuba that's where I went to school
ps1 66 and the whole time even though my
mom had the ball you say New Jersey my
Santeria godmother was one hundred forty
eighth and Broadway so on my weekends I
spent it up there with [ __ ] kids who
live nine to an apartment with a [ __ ]
fan you know meanwhile I was living with
my own air condition of a cable [ __ ]
TV feeling like a [ __ ] Savage but I
always kept that New York flavour to me
you know I left an 84 before the [ __ ]
[ __ ] really broke out but as I was
leaving even one of my favorite weed
spots along
forty-eight between Broadway and
Amsterdam do you know that in 1983 they
already had a punch card product while I
get by twelve and get one lifetime get
one free they used to call their weed
the master mix they mix the Buddha with
the cents and that was their master mix
and I'll never forget one day I went
there in June of 85 and I tried to get
weed and people like they know we do you
know moisture straight up crack from
this block I was like wow the
neighborhood changed that quick that's
why you shocked me when you said that
you could still get drugs in this city I
very funny people's right now I mean
kidding me but it's still New York I
don't know who did I mean I just I mean
I don't like I said I don't know but you
know what I mean come on you gotta be
serious
it's [ __ ] New York City man is
comical so what's next for you my
brother you're a man of a thousand ideas
I just I'm just gonna stop in your head
then you [ __ ] head this [ __ ]
voodoo weed to it I'm just gonna really
make your head go off and that's some
natural wine to that I'm really spinning
I'm just [ __ ] spinning all over the
place I just need somebody that's taking
notes from things when but like you said
about the New York City thing I feel
like that's just that's what gives a lot
that's what gives me my edge I feel
whatever edge I do have just just that
that's savviness you know just being
around all that [ __ ] and just being in
[ __ ] streets you have to walk blocks
and there's different things around all
over the place
different people different types of
schemes going on and different types of
players you know just so [ __ ] it's
different than growing up and [ __ ] a
suburb with lots of houses that are nice
and you hear the birds chirping and the
dog
and everyone was just happy I live in
Hell right now because in many ways I
wanted my daughter to experience the
same streets I grew up in you know let's
see what it was like it was just
different times that we live in
different in a different [ __ ] world
today you know and that's that's
something I always wanted for how to
[ __ ] live in New York City for a year
it - check it out
explore explore you know disguise that's
what it is
it gives you the idea that the sky's the
limit you look at everything in New York
and it's like [ __ ] man I could be there
too it gives you that it gives you that
boost that sky's the limit and that's
how I feel are you doing great man
appreciate them know what's the next do
you have a new album coming up no
[ __ ] album what I got a [ __ ]
cookbook coming out and within the same
two weeks August 25th is the album
blue-chip 7,000 the book [ __ ] that's
delicious an annotated guide to eating
well co-written with Rachel Wharton an
amazing writer
she [ __ ] captured my essence
perfectly just a hundred things I love
in this book 40 recipes all kinds of
beautiful you got things from a [ __ ]
steak sandwich that you can't really
make because I got some of the
ingredients from a [ __ ] wine maker in
Monty Falco Umbria and Italy - [ __ ]
haagen-dazs vanilla ice cream with white
truffle shaved all over it [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] olive oil so a nice [ __ ]
hamburger with truffles and just bacon
it's [ __ ] stupid actually now that I
think about it wonton soup kale crispix
you know like [ __ ] it's just not one
time - but your flavor exactly this is
exactly this is what I [ __ ] with man
this is what I [ __ ] with I like the
wonton soup and it has the pork chopped
up in it the red one the red pork notice
all shu pork right
I went to San Francisco's last week we
you guys were at and we're gonna buy a
house of them never house whatever and I
wanted a [ __ ] tie no it's Chinese
Chinese my straight-up Chinese very
[ __ ] legendary lying down and half
the block the whole [ __ ] Anna
now session one probably right I take
those home there Hunan I had garlic beef
I got a dollar house of House of hand
[ __ ] on what's-his-name sent me the
name I walked up there blade way guys I
had now you know I'm in New York City
dude bro
I like the egg roll I like the [ __ ]
spare rib I like the
egg-drop soup I like that [ __ ] really
good it's not even called war one time
in the East Coast
no just wonton soup it's called
something else no no no no they did they
do it right explain where I grew up was
just one time
super had one time to head the slice of
beef and it had the veggies in it yeah
but the problem is like here if you go
for one time soup it's basically for one
tons and a chicken
Chinese broth that could have came out
of a [ __ ] cat when you go to New York
those spots of oldest spots it always
felt like the broth was made for that
soup right anybody here catching on
saying T everything felt like it [ __ ]
belong oh yeah with one you get a soup
where's or melds together and it's just
harmony this is really nothing like it
the [ __ ] good doesn't you know
everyone thinks that the you know you
make a good soup or the Spanish make a
good soup but the [ __ ] Chinese they
have a [ __ ] very underrated soup
which is harmonious and always you know
you don't want to pick up shorty
the medal see the [ __ ] medal that's
something you don't see no war I'll
never get that here so I gotta wait it's
good for me I don't hello eat this
you're the constant I stay on the
healthy side you're right they don't use
the medal anymore - Chinese fun no they
don't use metal no [ __ ] now if it has
the medal that's how you know that I
[ __ ] around you follow me now one
does he knew posh oh come on on Vice
later face [ __ ] goddamn land oh [ __ ]
that's delicious with wood doing some
classic [ __ ] we're doing the original
episodes that were on the internet first
you know we're taking a lot of that [ __ ]
and putting it on television revamping
it doing a little narrative I'm over
there I'm taking pisses throw into
[ __ ] scenes while I'm taking a piss
it's beautiful it's like you know
exactly it's beautiful it's beautiful so
all the FTD classics come out August
24th on Vice land that's gonna be
beautiful ten episodes you're gonna see
the humble beginnings of all of the show
you know it's not like it's [ __ ]
blown out of proportion like we're
[ __ ] the Kardashians or some [ __ ]
but you know people like the [ __ ]
thing speaking of me got to keep that
[ __ ] on speaking of the internet ones is
there anything you like more than that
baklava that pocket well your aunt may
look just amazing she's an incredible
woman I love her very much
I mean I going all around the world must
be still special yeah I mean you know I
ate at the number one restaurant in the
world at the time [ __ ] Italian guy
Massimo Bottura
any [ __ ] hand-fed me mad different
things
where was the restaurant located in
Modena in Italy you know that's where
they made balsamic vinegar
[ __ ] Maserati I think it's either
Lamborghini or Ferrari the I and for
sure Ducati it's a little [ __ ]
ancient town where they [ __ ] slow
food and fast cars you know I mean that
was pretty phenomenal to be hand fed by
a genius what do they cook for you well
one of the dishes is he did
[ __ ] parmigiano-reggiano five
different ages in five different ways
which is he took a young one and made
like a cloud of it then he took a little
bit older made a [ __ ] little like
cheesecake of it then he took another
one and made a sauce of it then he took
another one and made a crisp of it then
he took another one and made some other
if I forgot the last one oh and the last
bite was he takes a [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] four-year-old piece and throws
it in your mouth at the end
[ __ ] mind-blowing [ __ ] it's
mind-blowing to be able to think about
to do these things while he's giving you
the you think of did he watch this [ __ ]
in the head that this guy's gryson
that's [ __ ] madam even give a [ __ ] I'm
sick [ __ ] mom I'm sweating I'm happy
it's like crazy it's like I'm getting
high that was pretty [ __ ] phenomenal
actually you're pretty [ __ ]
interesting dude man
I [ __ ] what you having the music to have
the videos to the cooking background to
just the reefer now is the city now he's
running with a Dominican from the Bronx
he's just a solid [ __ ] he's a
[ __ ] Dominican Puerto Rican he's
[ __ ] he's terrible in all ways but
he's good in a lot of ways too so he has
amazing what you can do it's real skinny
white dude from Detroit
this guy's was super bad you know he
does but he's a [ __ ] good producer
man he's really one of the best
producers out there
he's innovated a [ __ ] sound sam-i-am
and he's an innovator
the specific sound and he's a [ __ ]
genius he literally is a [ __ ] in quit
you wouldn't think this [ __ ] little
neurotic [ __ ] is a is there anything
computer we could find a close-up to
show this stuff you want to put some
[ __ ] sam-i-am what do you want to
play do it let's play that fire fire one
that I like the one with the stupid
stupid beat the one I wanted to rhyme
over the one you're rapping over that I
wanted to take you off of it's like with
violins you [ __ ] prick come on you
act like you don't know what song how
many songs do you have that I like Jesus
Christ you kidding me are you kidding me
right now the one I like all which one
is a good one you [ __ ] them freakin out
on you right now you know the hot one
from one of those albums that you put
out it was a good one man it was like a
three bar it wasn't like it was a three
UT please could we please find Sam I am
Sam I am such a [ __ ] what thank
Action Bronson guess what
[Music]
don't forget go to Hana calm right now
press it Church and get 10% off the
Liberty house I want that gang [ __ ]
Bronson I all that [ __ ] [ __ ] what do
you feel like what are they sling and I
want to thank [ __ ] utopia peanut
butter macaroons I might need another
one
to take the edge off you don't say it
was a song she wasn't rapping on it I
love you guys we'll see you one day haze
Saturday night ice house [ __ ] 7:30
stay black
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]